well the sewers canal is a 120 mile
piece of water which connects the
mediterranean to the
red sea and provides the shortest
ceiling between asia
and europe the 400 meter long
200 000 ton vessel ran aground on
tuesday blocking the entire
passageway now diggers are currently
trying to
excavate the bow of the ship while
tugboats are attempting to
pull and push the boat free specialist
salvage companies have been brought in
to try and re-float it
one option could be to dredge the sand
and silt
below the ship and remove fuel and cargo
on board in an attempt to lighten it and
help it float away now skies helen ann
smith has the details in the sewers
canal
problems are stacking up a super tanker
blocking a marine super highway
causing a super-sized problem for trade
worldwide
the ever given's been here three days
now a team of tugboats are trying to
shift it
the concept is that you remove the sand
and the silt around the bulbs bow the
bits in contact with the canal
and try and remove as much as possible
so that the tugs have got a better
chance of pulling the vessel back off
the the edge of the canal and back into
the center of the canal
and this is why the stakes are so high a
maritime traffic jam with a massive
price tag
12 percent of global trade uses this
route nearly
300 million pounds worth every single
hour
the impact is global in nature as time
ticks by
stuck vessels tick up over 250 now and
counting
to move goods from china to the uk via
the suez canal
is just over 10 000 nautical miles and
would usually take 21 days
those stuck could re-route perhaps round
the cape of good hope
but it would add seven days and almost
four thousand nautical miles to the
journey
and cost nearly three hundred thousand
pounds per vessel
it's a costly choice some are already
taking with worldwide ramifications
equipment that's going on to a
manufacturing line doesn't get there
at the time when the manufacturing line
lead needs it
and that just creates a delay in
manufacturing so it can have ripple
effects across the whole
economy because a lot of inventories
rely on just-in-time delivery
and this is obviously going to affect
that these aren't the chairs you like
with the table
and those ripples will be felt by
british companies and british customers
the cotswolds company is one it has 1.7
million pounds worth of furniture orders
stuck
on a hundred containers yet more
problems
after a year of pandemic and pain our
teams have been working really hard
for the last couple of days and we'll be
over the weekend to make sure
that all of our lead times represented
are accurate and that all of our
customers are updated proactively
the retail industry as a whole has had a
well-publicized extremely difficult year
um a lot of shops are looking forward to
reopening
and they're doing so with the prospect
of not being entirely sure when the
products they're selling are arriving
experts have warned of structural
problems if the vessel remains wedged
those involved say strong winds cause
this
it'll need more than just strong will to
move it
helen ann smith sky news